Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Through the power of computer
graphics research, today,
we can write wondrous programs which can simulate
all kinds of interactions in virtual worlds.
These works are some of my favorites, and
looking at the results, one would think that
these algorithms are so advanced, there is
hardly anything new to invent in this area.
But as amazing as these previous techniques
are, they don’t come without limitations.
Alright, well, what do those limitations look
like? Let’s have a look at this example. The
water is coming out of the nozzle, and it behaves
unnaturally. But that’s only the smaller problem,
there is an even bigger one. What is that
problem? Let’s slow this down, and look carefully.
Oh! Where did the water go? Yes, this is
the classical numerical dissipation problem
in fluid simulations, where due to an averaging
step, particles disappear into thin air.
And now, hold on to your papers and let’s see if
this new method can properly address this problem.
And…oh yes! Fantastic!
So it dissipates less. Great! What else does this
do? Let’s have a look through this experiment
where a wheel gets submerged into sand, that’s
good, but…the simulation is a little mellow.
You see, the sand particles
are flowing down like a fluid,
and the wheel does not really roll up the
particles in the air. And the new one.
So, apparently, it not only
helps with numerical dissipation,
but also with particle separation
too. More value. I like it.
If this technique can really solve these two
phenomena, we don’t even need sandy tires and
water sprinklers to make it shine, there are
so many scenarios where it performs better
than previous techniques. For instance, when
simulating this non-frictional elastic plate
with previous methods, some of the particles get
glued to it. And, did you catch the other issue?
Yes, the rest of the particles also
refuse to slide off of each other.
And now, let’s see the new method. Oh my! It
can simulate these phenomena correctly too!
And it does not stop there. It also simulates
strand-strand interactions better than previous
methods. In these cases, sometimes the
collision of short strands with boundaries
was also simulated incorrectly. Look at how all
this geometry intersected through the brush.
And the new method? Yes, of course,
it addresses these issues too.
So, if it can simulate the movement and
intersection of short strands better…does
that mean that it can also perform higher-quality
hair simulations? Oh yes, yes it does! Excellent!
So, as you see, the pace of progress
in computer graphics research
is absolutely stunning. Things
that were previously impossible
can become possible in a matter of just
one paper. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!